hey Vsauce Michael here and today I'm in
my apartment but when I was in Kansas
with family my dad lit off what is known
as a quarter stick
but don't worry absolutely no children
were around okay look the point is that
today we're gonna talk about explosives
let's begin way down the scale with
black powder or smokeless powder which
many modern rounds use
now usually smokeless powder doesn't
even detonate instead it deflagration
eclis an explosion is only a detonation
when the material or the gases expelled
travel faster than the speed of sound if
the explosion is subsonic you're only
dealing with a deflagration now we want
a bullets propellant to delegate not
detonate because we want it to have
enough power to move the ball it quickly
but not releases energy so fast as to
damage the gun or ourselves take a look
at some smokeless powder lit in the open
and slow motion it burns very strongly
and quickly but at all times
the gases it expels never exceed the
speed of sound and no shockwave is
produced we're looking at deflagration
here not detonation to compare this is
nitroglycerin it's so fragile you hit it
with a hammer and it detonates even at a
slower speed we can see that all the
material immediately explodes consumer
fireworks use black powder gunpowder and
as such they don't have enough power to
really ever be said to detonate the same
goes for that quarter stick you saw my
dad light off
and m-80s cherry bombs are louder and
often illegal but they burn flash powder
not a high explosive like dynamite but
it doesn't mean fireworks can't be
amazing currently some of the largest
shells in use are 48 inches across
when exploded in the air a 48 inch shell
looks like this or like this oh yeah
when they fail to launch and burst on
the ground instead it looks like this
[Applause]
but let's move on to detonations no
matter what material releases the energy
whether it's a conventional explosive or
a nuclear bomb or an asteroid impact or
an earthquake they are all commonly
measured by saying how much TNT you
would have to detonate to get an
equivalently strong explosion to give
you a sense of scale here is the
detonation of approximately 100 tons of
TNT by a defense contractor disposing of
explosives unlike deflagration
detonations produce a shockwave which is
just that a wave made of areas of high
pressure and low pressure this explosion
was so powerful the area of low pressure
had such low pressure that water vapor
in the air around it condensed
momentarily which formed this cloud and
here's a video of an explosion where the
shockwave is particularly visible as it
approaches and hits the cameraman
you can also see shock condensation
clouds around these explosions set off
by the United States in Hawaii in 1965
the US wanted to know how nuclear
attacks would affect naval ships so they
detonated an equivalent amount of TNT on
an island with US ships anchored nearby
this pile contains 500 tons of TNT
waiting to explode when it does it looks
like this earlier the u.s. tested actual
nuclear weapons to see how underwater
detonations might affect our ships this
underwater nuclear explosion is much
larger the equivalent of not 100 tons of
TNT not 500 tons but 8,000 tons
for comparison the atomic bomb dropped
on Hiroshima in 1945 exploded with the
energy of 15,000 tons of TNT the single
most physically powerful device ever
used by humanity was the Tsar bomb the
Soviet Union tested it in 1961 far up
north away from civilization it was
detonated two and a half miles above the
surface of the earth to minimize its
destruction which was unprecedented by
man the Tsar bomb exploded with a power
equivalent to fifty million tons of TNT
the mushroom cloud from the Tsar bomb
extended beyond our normal atmosphere
into the mesosphere and dwarfed the
largest clouds from us detonations it
was so large that comparatively the
bombs dropped on Japan well there on the
graph way down there but at the end of
the day nothing can beat supernovas the
explosion of an entire star while 50
million tons may sound like a lot one
supernova is estimated to give off the
energy equivalent of ten octillion
million tons of tnt I leave you with the
cannon developed by the US to shoot a
normal little cannonball except that it
carried a nuclear warhead I'm pretty
sure you can pick these up at Bass Pro
Shop but regardless be sure you're
subscribed to Vsauce so you don't miss
anything coming up and as always thanks
for watching